[Music]
so
[Music]
hey i'm christian i'm an outdoor
adventure photographer living full time
on the road for three years
so the last time we caught up i
mentioned that i was spending two months
here in jackson wyoming
time has flown by and i only have one
week left before i hit the road again
so i thought i'd show you a day in the
life here in the tetons
looking after jack getting out into the
mountains and shooting for a photo
assignment along the way
thanks for being here i hope you guys
like this one
[Music]
please
[Music]
good
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so i got this bike it's an electric bike
and i absolutely love it
it folds in half so it does fit in the
van but um
takes up a lot of space and it's really
really heavy
so it's really hard to get in and out of
the van
i might get a rack for the back of the
van but for now this is what i'm doing
so while we head out toward the tetons i
want to share a little bit about this
video sponsor
chirp audiobooks listening to audiobooks
while traveling has become one of my
favorite ways to pass the
time especially when driving long
distances hiking
cooking biking or even just spending
rainy days in the van
i'm currently listening to the monkey
wrench gang by edward abbey
he also wrote desert solitaire which is
one of my favorite books
i downloaded a couple books for under
five dollars including euro badass by
jen sincero
chirp is unique in that it offers deals
of up to 95
off and unlike other audiobook retailers
there's no subscription fee or monthly
commitment
you can get 50 off your first book using
the code shaffer50 at checkout
i'll put a link to their website my
caption below also if you guys are up
for it i would love to hear what books
you're reading or listening to
i always love a good book recommendation
[Music]
so
oh he's just playing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you